so we have four micronus and we have a
question already up here in the back
right hi thank you madam secretary my
name is cheyenne ellis and i'm an
american here at living in copenhagen
prior to moving to Denmark I worked in
Washington DC at the Department of State
along with suit Ambassador Susan Jacobs
on parental child abduction cases
however today my question is on gender
imbalance in the workplace recently the
EU has proposed to initiate mandatory
quotas to ensure more women are
represented in top management positions
in European businesses do you feel a
quota system is necessary to increase
more female CEOs or do you feel like
this is a self-regulating issue which
needs no policy intervention well
Cheyenne that's a question I've wrestled
with for a long time and I you know I
don't think that there is a right answer
to that question because there does seem
to be a glass ceiling in nearly every
society not all of them I think that you
know you now have a woman Prime Minister
you have a woman head of state be going
to Norway and Sweden and Finland all of
whom have had women in the very top
positions in government but even in
those four countries there's not that
level of representation on a sustained
basis in the corporate world so is there
some intervention that could encourage
businesses to look more broadly to
recruit women I'm sure that there could
be whether it's quotas or whether quotas
are the right answer I will leave that
debate to the Europeans to decide
whether it's right for them but
certainly it's been our experience that
it still is more difficult for women to
make it to the top in either politics or
business in our country the United
States would never go for quotas but I
think there has to be
recognition that in the absence of a
much more self-conscious outreach for
women to be on corporate boards in the
pipeline for corporate leadership
positions it's not likely to change so
I'm hoping that as we experiment with
this in different parts of the world we
will learn more and if the EU adopts
quotas I will be very interested in
seeing how that works or whether it is
unsuccessful because people just
flat-out resistant I hope though that we
can finally get over what has been a
historic gender imbalance in both
politics and business because I think in
the 21st century women's empowerment is
one of the most important goals for the
world to aim toward thank you for that
answer Madam Secretary let's go to the
front left Ingrid please hi my name is
mess I wanted to ask you for a student
of international affairs and global
politics where do you believe a future
in in these areas live for us I put it
in the UN on the national stage or maybe
in the NGOs and guess the question is
also which institutions do you think the
future of political or global politics
will be shaped well I'm glad you're
interested in these areas and I think
they're our futures in all three of what
you said I think the multilateral
organizations are in great need of
reform and young people need to be
committed not only to a career but to a
reform agenda within the institutions
because I think that they haven't kept
up with the times I don't think that
they operate as efficiently as they
could they get too bureaucratic to
weighted down by internal process
instead of external results I think NGO
is our a lean mean way often of
intervening of making your voices heard
one of my goals is to promote civil
society in places that have never known
civil society and to make it legitimate
to convince governments that having
people who advocate for the environment
or for children with disabilities or for
the arts or for electoral reform is an
essential part of the democratic process
and then government obviously I believe
strongly that if we're lucky enough to
live in a vibrant democratic society you
can either be totally apathetic which
then leaves the decision-making to
people who may disagree with you
completely or you can be an active
citizen participate participant in
politics or you can even go so far as
being active in a political party and
running for office it's hard I'm not
going to sugarcoat it it's not easy
being in politics anywhere in the world
today in any democracy but I certainly
hope that a lot of young people like
yourself we'll look at that third
alternative as much as the first to
Madam Secretary if you were 18 again
living in the world as of today with all
the economic instability and uncertainty
what would you choose to do for a living
that's a great question well you know I
became a lawyer and I practice law and I
did a lot of work on behalf of defending
children abused and neglected children
and working for legislative change on
behalf of children and I always find
myself attracted to trying to work on
behalf of those who are marginalized or
left out so I would probably do the same
thing whether i mean i've started NGOs
i've served on the boards of large NGOs
and help to direct them and you know I
think there will always be a voice even
in privileged societies like ours for
those
who are voiceless and so I I like
feeling that maybe I can you know help
make a difference in someone's life and
then the work around the world is a full
agenda particularly on behalf of women
and children so I think I'd probably be
doing something in that area which is
what I was doing before I got into
politics let's go to Row 3 here please
first of all it's a huge honor Madam
Secretary my name is Anna I'm a PhD
fellow in American Studies and I have a
question about Syria of course one of
the reasons why the operation in Libya
went so we'll was because you had the
support of other Arab countries which
role what role do you think arab
countries will play in the solution of
the Syrian problem and also you say that
the Russians are the main problem why
there's not a sort of solution in the
international community at this point
are there other sort of regional and
national differences between Syria and
Libya that makes it difficult to to
intervene that's a great great question
there are certainly significant
differences Syria is much larger it's a
much more diverse society so that
different groups within Syria are
worried about what comes after Assad and
are not unified in the way that Libya
became there is a professional military
there was not in Libya Gaddafi relied on
a very small group of military personnel
augmented by mercenaries there was a
opposition in Libya that did represent
the country that's not been yet possible
in Syria we've all been working to try
to promote that there was a a safe haven
that could be operated out of that
Benghazi became and then you could move
west the air defenses in Syria are
significantly tougher than Libya the
Arab League called for action by the
Security Council the Arab League has
supported the Kofi Annan mission they
haven't been united to call for military
action yet and most importantly the
Security Council in the case of Libya
was willing to act and then NATO could
put together a coalition that was
augmented by Arab countries willing to
fly the no-fly zone even carry out
strikes so really those conditions do
not exist with respect to Syria as of
yet there's also a lot of regional
difficulty or complexity that has to be
dealt with I mean you know Jordan is
right on the border of Syria you know
they have to worry about their own
territorial integrity and safety Turkey
has that long border they worry about
whether they make themselves more
vulnerable to the Kurdish terrorist
threat that they are so focused on you
go down the line it's quite a difficult
set of factors to balance its next door
to Lebanon which as you know fought a
brutal civil war all those years and the
demographics of the population are not
so dissimilar except in terms of numbers
but the basic demographics are quite
similar between the two countries we've
already seen the conflict wash over and
a Lebanon and a lot of people are trying
to figure out what could be an effective
intervention that wouldn't cause more
death and suffering and in Libya partly
because it was a small population in a
asked expanse much of it not
particularly populated there was a
theater for intervention that was quite
successful in avoiding civilian
casualties that seems much more
difficult if not impossible now we're
thinking about all of this there's all
kinds of both civilian and humanitarian
and military planning going on but the
factors are just not there you ask very
good question guys thanks for doing my
job so well let's go to the far back
left hi my name is Heidi of study
information management and I have
recently applied for an internship at
MoMA in New York and that made me
research a bit about the American
education system we have a really good
one here but don't you find that you
leave big part of the American youth on
the ground because they can't afford or
their parents can't afford to give them
an education I think it's one of our
biggest domestic challenges now
historically our public education system
worked well enough for the vast majority
of Americans and a relatively small
percentage of Americans went to college
but by the end of the 20th century and
certainly now into the 21st century the
disparities in education between our
most privileged young people and our
poorest has gotten much broader and the
cost of going to college has skyrocketed
so we have increasing numbers of young
people who are coming out of college
with huge debt and it's really
regrettable and there there has to be a
reckoning about this because we're not
in my view providing the best education
we should for children who are
not in the best of circumstances and we
make a post-high school education very
expensive and we don't have enough of
the right sort of skills training
because one of the great ironies in our
current economic situation is you can
see job postings for thousands of jobs
but we don't have the people in the
places with the skills to take the jobs
so we have to close that gap and it's
it's something that I care deeply about
I know President Obama does as well and
we're going to see what more we can do
from the federal government although
final thing I would say on this is you
know much of education starts in the
family and requires a combination of
encouragement and discipline that
families have to provide and then our
education system in public schools is
run by local and state governments so
our complicated federal system makes
change more challenging but we have to
figure out how we're going to do it okay
Ingrid let's go to the front row middle
please be careful not to break a leg
please hi my name is Tina and I studied
law at copenhagen university my question
is about the International Criminal
Court your husband been told till he
signed the Rome Statute in two thousand
and what the Bush administration later
unsigned it you seem to have a rather
positive approach to the ICC so my
question is whether you plan to sign re
sign and ratify the Rome Statute during
your time as Secretary of State well I
do think that the ICC is an important
tribunal and I thank you for noticing
that we have in the last three and a
half years increased our
involvement with the ICC the head of our
our legal department at the State
Department is a renowned international
lawyer the former dean of the Yale Law
School and we have promoted more
exchanges more discussions but at this
point we we know that there would be no
appetite in our Congress under current
circumstances to ratify America's
membership so short of that we're going
to continue to do what we can to support
the important work that the ICC does
Madame secretary i would like to squeeze
in a little question that we also got
from a lot of our viewers we asked on
Facebook that they could they could ask
you questions and and thousands of
people around the globe especially women
and see you as a role model because you
have had a remarkable career you're the
first lady you've been the senator for
New York and now you're the Secretary of
State and can you tell us a little thing
about how has this journey been for you
personally well personally it's been a
surprise because when I was sitting
where you would be sitting I never
imagined that I would marry someone
who'd become a president or that I would
be a senator from New York or that I
would be a secretary of state so my my
journey has been not only surprising but
you know very gratifying to me and
people ask me all the time if I have any
advice and it's hard to put yourself in
anyone else's shoes but I think for both
young men and young women to go back to
the previous question education remains
such a passport to any option that you
might decide to choose and it doesn't
always have to be conventional education
people i know very successful people
Bill Gates obviously dropped out of
Harvard but he was always
learning and he was always alert and he
was always taking in what he was
interested in and was able to channel
his passion into creative innovation so
staying involved and and aware of what's
going on around you I also always hope
that people develop some sense of social
responsibility that if you're fortunate
enough to be educated healthy living in
a democracy having more control over
your own life although it probably
doesn't seem like it from time to time
then the vast majority of people who've
ever lived in the history of the world
have had then what can you do to give
back as well as get ahead and for young
women I think that the historic
questions remain I mean how can you have
a life and make a living how can you
have relationships how can you have
children and be active in whatever you
choose and it just takes a lot of focus
and a decision that you're going to live
your life in a way that meets your
aspirations to the best of your ability
and then life happens you know I mean
you want on my case I walk across the
the lounge of the Yale Law School and
here's some guy saying you know not only
that we grow the biggest watermelons in
the world and I said who is that
and the friend I was wizard well that's
Bill Clinton he's from Arkansas that's
all he ever talks about and I I'd never
been to Arkansas out obviously this was
all new to me and so I took a leap of
faith and I think it's worked out pretty
well but it's a you know it has been
because of choices I made I tried to be
the lead actor if you will in my own
life and not to be a bit player and not
to let things happen to me but to try to
decide how i was going to respond to
whatever happened and no you just you
just keep moving forward every single
day later I'm gonna ask you where you're
going to move to Oh